so I got a question for you it's just a
question no big deal
can't wait are you still doing the way
to go podcast no you know what dude turn
this off right now why and turn on
congratulations the podcast okay is that
that's what it's called that's what's
called my show you confuse it with what
no good I thought way to go I always
confuse it whether it is it the yeah I
know way to go you know I always think
of it as like woohoo cuz it's not cuz
it's amazing well it's not about well
here's my question this is and this is
here okay so you do it how long you been
doing the podcast 84 weeks
okay so okay here's the question what
why do you do it
B why do I do it because you know why do
you know why do it why there's an
appetite for it oh well how about that
that's what you would say in the biz
nothing there's an appetite don't people
go like this mmm what's on the menu
today and they [ __ ] go to my they
order my food there's also an appetite
for Arby's all right and you're saying
how I [ __ ] is like the [ __ ] Arby's
McDonald's and what's yours dude no but
see in in this podcast this pocket this
is that this is not me talking but the I
just say this is the consensus a
scientific consensus of the review of
you while the reviews I don't know if
there's been this like this podcast is
there two words that I hear constantly
right life change
no do okay that's what I hear no you
don't but that's what that's what that's
when you when you boil it down there's a
lot of things said no but when you boil
it down to its its components it's
essential elements it's that you hear
towards life Jay no they don't that's
what I hear no you know what I hear you
know you know what it is what change
your life don't listen to this not
change your life that you're mixing up
the [ __ ] words that you're doing but
but for you like what are you saying
that they don't know dude that's what
are you saying that they don't know by
the way thank god [ __ ] Brendan's not
here because he's too big for this room
this [ __ ] little
room dude and by the way I asked for
tissues because I need to blow my nose
and they brought me [ __ ] what the
dentist used to [ __ ] put it around
your [ __ ] when you're bleeding and
drooling so that's cool
clean up dude sorry there's so much [ __ ]
around here there's a lot of shitty [ __ ]
there's a candles we don't use there's
some letters on the ground Ken like chin
look at a cleaning service signs on the
ground this place this bird down there
yeah this place is not remember last
time let the hangover it looks like like
yeah I was in no you weren't you weren't
in it I was three guys were you I do
that because I have flames right here
that can so that's what's up so I go
we've had literally never spoken about
that terrible no it's not terrible Oh
[ __ ] amazing but why did you go did
you wake up and you were like okay this
is Tara coffee and I'm tired of that I'm
gonna get flames on my hand you've got a
keen eye thing allow you there's nothing
about you nothing that would that would
signify flame are you [ __ ] out of
your mind dude what about you know what
you're not your dude I'm on that's right
that's why I did no bonfire don't do
that okay but that is like a terrible
80s Ryan no not and there's nothing
about you that sweetie there's nothing
there you are basically low-energy all
that old [ __ ] you're human broccoli
that's I'm not kidding
no it's mine to be that way but you
you're for you you're pale I'm gonna get
a nap all the time nah bro I'm killing
it what are you doing on the phone so no
no don't do that
yeah dude don't do that don't snap snap
this don't stop no way dude
Harel terrible way to introduce you to
them so it doesn't catch fire because I
don't want [ __ ] fire to catch see
it's my retardant you're putting water
I'm gonna get water on this side I'm
gonna go [ __ ] stop it no stop it's
not to get water on that side they're
not hot I am [ __ ] no why did you get
but why did you say let me see that
okay it's so annoying Chris fire man on
fire like my last special dude you don't
get it it has layers no no my podcast
rips my podcast refuge dude what does
that mean it rips what do you mean it
ribs you know when you're going on a
rollercoaster or intersect that's when
you turn on my podcast
that's what's HAP and then and then once
it starts dude you're [ __ ] you're got
you oh and then you start going down oh
my god that [ __ ] [ __ ] ass bar on
right it's just you huh it's not you
what you say about bar the bar put that
[ __ ] bar on put that [ __ ] ass bar on
so you don't fall out while your list
okay so say you I've had people fall my
guess is is is four is what people
should listen to and they're working out
yeah well no well if I mean it's very
dangerous cuz I've had people I in there
fall out of their car listening on the
freeway yeah it's not believe that I
believe that you're lying they fall they
fall out of you can't recognize when
you're driving down this oh dude you
know what the [ __ ] most hilarious
[ __ ] was dude I was at Starbucks and
coffee bean today because I got two
coffees for me because last time I got
to call
and I gave one to you and your [ __ ]
sweet tart tart Nass wouldn't drink it
you know these terms sweetheart NASA
might go but do my shows people go you
got a sweet tooth oh don't point things
that people probably Americans then I
got a deal with me gone yeah I'm a sweet
tart Tyrell dude
young guys are like you got a sweet
tartness as they drive by I don't like
it
well don't be [ __ ] sweet tart tart
there's nothing sweet tart tart about me
at all I'm a [ __ ] hard older dude
yeah I've seen a lot of [ __ ] dude I get
tight you know it's so hilarious I was
at [ __ ] Starbucks getting my second
coffee today yeah and the kind goes like
this I came in today without laughing
he goes he does Chris what if you are
not a household name so don't act like
the [ __ ] guy at Starbucks I mean I
laughed and he played it good he was
like what and I go like this I go like
this I looked at him and I go like this
Chris yeah people actually I have family
members who go what's that guy crystally
delial I know they do so your name is
not because they have a listening
problem and not during problem what's
that guy Chris D'Elia like dude and then
what some people go they don't do that I
just heard famous they don't do that
dude think I'll use what the [ __ ] bro
did you shoot this morning yeah hey dude
you were a little balmy no yeah it's too
early to be [ __ ] doing your second
job I agree it's 11:00 do you when
you're on a set of him oh it's boring as
[ __ ] yet if we're ignoring this [ __ ]
yeah especially if you're doing a draw
which I like to do but like when you're
doing a drama like I did a drama last
year that didn't come out yet but like
it
people like was it fun and I'm like
that's the wrong word are you naughty
fun yeah it's like you're doing drop it
like first of all in the movie that pert
the the lead was dying of cancer that's
that the what the story is about
tomorrow you're like you're like sitting
there being on emotional and it's like
cutting I do it again you got doing nine
times and you're like you're not having
fun in between because it doesn't call
for it and you don't want to [ __ ] up
this the vibe of the so you can't lay
around yeah so you're just like chilling
and you're like oh this person has
cancer you got pretend princess cancer
it's so fun is the wrong word
I mean and here's the other thing too
when you're in acting class they call it
keeping your preparation Oh
keeping your emotional catch later yeah
catch you later and so also so also what
what what you what it's just I forgot I
lost my train of thought because your
time how boring acting can be unset and
you can't play around it's just guys
cancer so you have to you have to be in
that yeah and then you just it's just
tough to be happy and fun and when
you're just doing that and you're oh
here's here's gonna say you you only
have if I was like the fourth biggest
role in the movie but you you still even
if you're like the fourth unless you're
like the guy in the movie or the other
person in the movie like the first two
yeah you've got about one or two good
scenes that were you're really doing
something now do you know how many times
you just got to walk in the door and put
your keys down that's a scene people
don't realize that I wish people see
what acting really is and how about when
they're at dates so when you do coverage
they shoot you and then they shoot the
other person you have to be behind the
camera in your lines so so much of it
now you know whether you're working with
like it doesn't matter how famous the
person is I don't care how big and
famous you're sometimes you have to be
in the background shot you have to be in
the background so you're just standing
around all day pretending to talk yeah
it's weird so many weird things about
like being on set and people and people
be like oh it's a weird thing to
complain about you make a lot of money
like you don't make that much money
doing that stuff you did you really
don't maybe one or two people making
yeah right but like you're done you
don't like you don't
make a lot like these actors that you
see in these you don't know their name
they're not making a lot of money not
only that their middle class they're
living a middle-class life
I don't care amenitized you've seen them
in in movies you know in LA oh you mean
babies yeah even bigger actors yet it's
fine but it's it's it's Travis but but
but but but it's true that unless you're
the one good thing about doing comedy is
you can be around funny [ __ ] people
so you're laughing when you're doing a
drama a little actors they they're good
at that but they don't have great senses
of humor yeah so then you're just kind
of there and yeah Eagles and [ __ ]
muffins from craft service and you're
just getting [ __ ] fat yeah I don't
get fat ankles but you shredded but but
no no no no but you know me I'm shred
you lost a lot of weight though I did
yeah so what's the deal
psoriasis oh I know bread and stuff so
you get psoriasis if you eat bread yeah
so I have to eat a certain diet pop star
[ __ ] pop super-lean no no is it that
or is it just that you don't be careful
my lacking what the more and more every
when I and I'm not saying you look a lot
like this person but them every time I
see you insulting I'm not this is I'm
not you know like something it's
actually not I know what you're saying
but I feel like you're gonna be insulted
I get it and I know I would feel that
way too but this is my guess so your I
know okay I'm a guest of the fighter and
the kid yeah okay don't be a dick I'm
not okay them every time I see you you
look more like the Cryptkeeper from and
you don't look a lot like it but it's
more more yeah you know they you know
they told you not to me
I told you not to be himself no no no so
why did you say that um you know what he
put no I'm saying you know any pops up
yeah he's a skeleton look at everything
I look like that the tells from the
Crypt Keeper he had a good run I mean
I'm not I'm not like he was popular he's
partner I think they're redoing it so
maybe you why don't you shave while you
let it grow all the way down to your
neck
time but if you have nothing but time
too busy you you have nothing but time
it did if I [ __ ] whatever what am I in
[ __ ] NSYNC let me tell you something
do it if you put any time into your
beard put a vest with a bunch of pockets
on it on and take a hike dude take a
[ __ ] hike what a vest with a bunch of
pockets on it
come on put it on thank God bro just let
your beard grow on that way bro you're
walking stick dude I would never put
lines or any sort of care into my beer
because of my [ __ ] in the way dude
I'm a [ __ ] guy I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm
gonna French it up here dude get outta
here I'm gonna [ __ ] bread I'm gonna
[ __ ] French head up dude I'm not
singing a play I tailor my beer don't
meet that doesn't mean I'm French this
is Italy yeah I mean you see I'm another
French man [ __ ] I keep breaking in
French now is sorry dude
don't play back in black it's gonna make
me mad know what I was going to do is
all right this is what I was going to do
dude what see the sound effects I mean
just because you tailor your beard I
don't
oh oh [ __ ] alert your oh you cut your
beard yeah I do i I'm an accurate
sometimes well don't do what I manicure
my beard sometimes Oh [ __ ] alert don't
just shave it and let it go that's what
you do
you can also there's nothing wrong with
bringing it down and keeping a nice line
here dude that is obnoxious it did you
what do you do you dude get up what do
you do you shave UIC's
I'll pepper your shave happy let your
cheek so they don't go too high yeah
dude happy are face up I can't wait to
get [ __ ] dude
know what I am ring with me bro what
what'd you say to me why don't you get
in the ring with me bro bro nah by the
way you paired up real nice for that
wouldn't you yeah well you would
wouldn't you bro [ __ ] the [ __ ]
microphone [ __ ] stand right here don't
bring your beard man
you're not gonna trim your blood would
you do if a guy looked at you and goes
for real and you're on the street the
guy goes hey Chris D'Elia right yeah you
[ __ ] bro
mmm-hmm you're [ __ ] cuz you were
doing stand-up and you insulted my girl
from the stage I'm gonna kick your
[ __ ] ass what would you say lawyer up
you're up you threatened a lawsuit I go
like this hold my watch to someone I
trust
what yep hold my watch and then you say
you would fight if it happens it happens
what are you gonna do how what are you
gonna throw your hands in the air and
just go wha nah dude mama bro I'm
spindly bro my knees my [ __ ] legs
with your legs there spin so if you take
you out with a thigh kick you take you
out of the thighs all right I accept it
[ __ ] you know what I mean what you
turn in Excel with it yeah turning
except turn and accept it and the back
of my thigh because it doesn't hurt as
much as in the [ __ ] right of myself
say you would you gotta matter you would
you don't present your IT band you give
them your hamstring yeah man and then
you counter oh yeah I got bro do I
counter yeah yeah uh I [ __ ] counter
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do okay I'm
gonna take your brother who's a smart
ass that sends me texts yeah like open
for me on the road I'm doing stand-up
now [ __ ] like my brother says I he says
[ __ ] like that sometimes just send me a
picture of him smiling I'm gonna smack
him around with an open hand for no
reason I'm gonna bully him push him down
push him into the bush it's no dude yeah
I'm gonna get his get his knees all
scraped up dude and you're gonna sit and
watch and all you're gonna do is go
don't know look Dawg I'm not gonna do
that don't and I'm not gonna listen no
I'm gonna I'm gonna shove your brother
around make him cry and I'm gonna get if
he has money in his pockets I'm gonna
reach in his pockets I'm gonna pull out
the money I'm take his keys well the
throw is key somewhere for no reason
well so I'm gonna bully I know you're
not gonna
you ain't gonna do jack no do it right
that's not true you're gonna do [ __ ]
jaw dude I'm done imposing my will on
all right on Matt yeah okay
dolia sure come up I'm gonna chest-bump
you no man knows gonna be on your nose
you can smell my breath okay and I'm
gonna go what right no watch no you're
not no you're not you're gonna go right
and you're gonna fall on your brother
I'm not keep and weep with him and you
guys gonna clutch each other mmm cry and
then you know what's gonna happen I'm
gonna fun Oh
peel out no your car nope and then
you're gonna pop up and you're gonna say
that's a keeper I go like this ageist
humor I ask cat if I was what you
thought you cuz you're a good-looking
older like middle-aged there you go yeah
there you go
we and I'm a young buck dude I am me
young you know what I realize 44 no you
know what I realize I'm young dude
that's what I realized
no I'm like what the [ __ ] why do I have
Benjamin buttons disease no I think I
got to a certain point where all of a
sudden I started walking back dude no
cuz your face I've decided is you have
your what you indent where your eyes are
so you have an hourglass face which to
me to me only to me I'm not trying to be
a dick about it okay but if you look at
your face in a vacuum
yeah without your personality right
personality and good hair but just the
face structure yeah is revolting no way
you're saying I got a peanut head in the
worst way and it's it's it's a marvel
that you get away with it rock yeah
don't lose your hair no I'm gonna I
don't like I say what I can't wait to do
a [ __ ] role where I just gotta shave
this [ __ ] off to play Pina No
Selena where the [ __ ] is peanut there he
is
and they go like this why are his
shoulders so broad cuz now I get it
right because then I get it now there's
hairs out there I get her off a lot of
months around hey bring up his Instagram
I'll say I can't help it
that's all things apply in the man it's
out of nowhere in it and it just out of
nowhere and it was like it
it was literally at like 1:00 in the
morning and it just said I have a
swimmer's body and I go dude and then I
just got a picture of him with a shirt
off
well like huh like that well look at him
just keep going I want to see well yeah
there I don't know just keep going like
that Kiki thing that was funny
the Kiki thing I did it oh yeah there's
the be various and there's some
computers there is it's so happy with
you you get a lot of a lot of female
attention on that [ __ ] post bro
chicks dude don't care man show me love
man what I don't I'm not gonna [ __ ] him
I'm not gonna [ __ ] me oh hey even why
would you even say I'm not gonna [ __ ]
dudes because it's ID equal to Ma who is
that guy who was your twin aw that guy's
a French Canadian comedian Wow yeah it's
so named Chris did yeah he his name's
Matt so that's pretty weird cuz my
brother's name but he is very cool I
like him
do you ever have fantasies of not doing
anything what do you mean I don't know
did you ever get to his chilling like I
just shot my special yeah so I don't now
I have to I I literally can't think of
joke one can't think of a [ __ ] like I
haven't even thought about stand-up but
I need to get back yeah but I'm like a
vessel you know I mean where the [ __ ]
experience comes in to me and then I
[ __ ] shoot it out right so I'm like
this just happened to me and then all of
a sudden I've got eight new minutes go
onstage dang it dang it dang it a banger
to the bang at a tonsil audience is like
how do I [ __ ] did I workout today and
then the next day dude I get a lot of
times I get [ __ ] you no emails none a
lot of emails from a bad way ya know and
they go like this dude I thought I was
like did I workout yesterday I'm like oh
yeah I went to the Chris D'Elia show
because my [ __ ] core
come on his [ __ ] solid right now know
a lot of guys I had a girl tell me I was
talking to this girl who was so dumb
mmm-hmm it was in a group and and and I
was at the Soho House night and there
were these film people and my friend
knew and mmm so far the mall they would
store yeah and there was this girl and
she was talking like this she kind of
was dragging out her words because she's
here and she doesn't she's got like
between managers right now that's
interesting as she was describing this
conditions because I've been having
medical issues I go watch because it's
like my this area here is like I feel
like I have really bad cramps a lot and
then I throw up but I think it's okay I
was like well you should go to the
doctor for that oh how long has that
been going
it's been going on for a while I was
like well of course go to the doctor I
don't have insurance right so I'm just
doing a lot of like T's which by the way
the T's are causing the cancer she's
getting but I dude do you do you go to
the doctor I takes me so long to go that
Donnie kill yeah I know it sucks my god
I had a sore throat for a while and it
was like two weeks no it wasn't no I
don't know but that can be a symptom no
and so I [ __ ] I finally and I for two
weeks you had so I so what what I think
what happened was but I think what
happened was I had two swollen glands
and then when that went away I got a
sore throat so I don't think it was the
same thing yeah but still I wasn't sure
so I finally went to the doctor like two
weeks I was like alright I'll just make
the appointment [ __ ] it and I did and I
went there and the doctor goes like this
it's viral it should be fine in a few
days you know I'm talking about hits so
annoying
oh cool here's a hundred bucks yeah now
of course that doesn't make that's what
still shouldn't be about you making
money it's not about making money it's
about me losing a hundred dollars which
doesn't make a [ __ ] damn dude
god dammit I have will try having
psoriasis I feel bad for people that
have diseases that do you have an
autoimmune disease there the [ __ ]
dermatologists are like well yeah I
could put you on this drug where that's
so strong you can't get life insurance
or here's a cream that doesn't work
shrug
they don't know what to do yeah so
father's a doctor this is how much
doctor yeah head I had the flu and that
I got it broke out like my legs and
stuff and and the so this I'll be the
dermatologist okay I went to school okay
just start describing okay have
psoriasis yeah so I got psoriasis I got
the flu and I broke out of my legs and
all that yeah so I don't know what to do
yeah well that's that's what happens
that'll happen
I say it hasn't gone away for six months
Lloyd the thing is is it hasn't gone
away for six months yeah yeah that'll
happen
I guess you could try son and oh that's
what it is I'll give you a steroidal
cream don't you overuse it just once a
day I guess I love when doctors say I
guess this is well a lot of the doctors
do a lot of times if I was a doctor yeah
I wanted to be a doctor and then [ __ ]
you come in and you say I've got a pain
in my side or something good I have a
pain in my side I [ __ ] that's my
doctor advice with addy how about I
didn't have a pain in my side mm-hmm
like on my side and I was like so I go
to the doctor and I'm like this doesn't
make sense why would I have a pain why
would I have one pain in my sinus
doesn't make sense sir doctor he does
all these tests he goes well your blood
your blood work is pretty outstanding
liver functions great so because I'll
send you down a surgeon I said I think I
have a hernia oh so I go to this surgeon
he's like this I'm cedars-sinai seen it
all he's like fifty I go I think I have
a hernia and he goes you do and I go
yeah he goes where is it again I go
right here and he goes hmm that's
interesting I know why you guys know
it's kind of fascinating I know it is
and he goes well it is in the sense that
you'd be the only person in history to
have a hernia there oh that's impossible
and then I go oh and he goes now I know
your next question is is that pain
something ominous and I go that is my
next question he goes no it's not no
that's not how things work I think what
you did is tore the lining on the inside
of your stomach which is why your doctor
said right oh yeah he goes okay
so you can get out of my office now
later who's so funny I was like okay
bye-bye
sometimes they cop an attitude though
you know yeah like all right what I got
to do I got a [ __ ] you know I had I
had a like a [ __ ] fissure in my
butthole
you know what I mean oh yeah yeah
because
don't drink enough water well are you
[ __ ] yeah no that's not it
dude that's the rumor so and the doc was
like I felt like the doctor was like I
can look in your butt oh god I mean such
a pain in the ass yeah
hey how about putting a suppository in
your butt though never done what really
yeah why do it when I was a baby when
you do it let me tell you something man
for the people out there that I've put
in medicine in there Bob why did you
have to put a suppose because I had the
[ __ ] vision I mean I was like 22 or
something so I got a fish or years ago
why would I would have a suppository
help your fever because it it's a cut in
there Oh inside yeah so you had to put
yeah the the suppository in there Wow
bro I was so nervous doing it and then
you do it it feels [ __ ] amazing dude
you go like this it's so you know what
it is soothing okay I don't know yeah
well you don't know well when you do
know no you're gonna call me up dude I
won't get there call me I don't get to
be my age the doctor sticks his finger
up your ass feels your prostate gland
and then every time he does he goes flat
as a pancake what does that mean oh but
I don't like that I don't like when he
blows his finger in your rump so don't
you have to do that when you're 40 or
something like that yeah you start you
start to have had have you ever had a
girl stick of no there no I don't like
Dutch I'm not crazy I had iiiii I mean
I've had girls like ask and want to do
it and I'm like nah nah yeah I'm not
into aspirin
nah nah neither am i I don't even like
necessarily doing it to a girl like I
don't really care yeah it's not that
like I'm grossed out I'm just like who
cares yeah yeah my friend my friend one
time I said he was talking about going
down because this any other thing and I
go yeah I'm not into like going down I
go but I'm not into licking her butt
you're saying this yeah and my buddy
goes what and I go well I'm not gonna
get in there goes why do you think your
tongue is show stop sticking right up
her ass and I go oh and he goes oh
you're gonna get [ __ ] on your tongue
gonna be a [ __ ] and he shamed me whoa
and I was like I don't all right but I
don't
no it's not where I go right away right
yeah I mean it depends on dude but you
don't know no it depends on what but
like but no it depends on what the
[ __ ] butthole looks like you know I
feel like I need to [ __ ] and see what a
picture of the girl's family if I'm
gonna [ __ ] eat her but for ya and be
like all right that's where you come
there are girls that you would yeah but
but there are girls that you like let me
see your family own they look a little
bit like darl X I'm keeping my tongue
away from your butthole yeah but if you
had all your family's very tethered and
look you know I mean I don't mean to be
gross about it but like oh okay well
your mom and dad are still together and
you've got a sister that looks Mormon
you know what I mean that's all I'm
saying that's the noise you make when
you're like will you eat my butt all can
I see photos of your family on vacation
like a crab in forgot in front of Mount
Rushmore that's what I do
if they're in front of an OTP betting
thing sure that's me running away and
then you see papers like this like a
cartoon
you see papers floating down to the
ground before they even hit the ground
I'm in my car no more yeah yeah yeah
that that so that's me have you ever had
but my what time I was there's this guy
and we knew and he goes my dad don't
keep around too close
I've already made I don't like him
around oh my gosh hmm
he's a wife-beater wasn't married I go
what you guys he hits girls did I know
his girlfriend he takes a hand or
sometimes really yeah it was funny too
because it did change how I looked at
him well of course it is you hit girls
I'm right sir I see you're a nice guy
here but when closed doors you might be
a bad dude I've never I've never met you
know I mean it's not a deal breaker if
it's a girl
yeah of course it is how do you know
you're growing you hit girls like what
do you mean you take a handle like who
are you closed doors yeah yeah but you
I've never
how did this guy know this that the guy
did it because he knows his girl he knew
I knew the guy like hey how you doing
yeah come around but he knew him well
and it was just weird dude
stories are so weird sometimes where you
go what the [ __ ]
I don't I that's just and you know then
again though the way he tells it
sometimes you don't know like what do
you what are you go I know the girl
she's not bruised up what's really going
on oh [ __ ] nur is he hitting her be home
yeah under the clothing line Jesus
Christ
cuz if you're gonna hit a girl is this
guy you are you telling me a story that
ends with and that man was me yeah it's
not a good way no dude
oh man you guys it's been great what
yeah well I gotta go right yeah it's
been 20 minutes y'all breaker dude I'm
the [ __ ] don't say the man okay oh why
you know why did you choose to wear a
shirt with that stupid that you bought
like that I did what it would why are
you into fashion alone hello okay look
another hair that fell out well not a me
are you your hair and it's okay but you
are losing your [ __ ] hair oh that's
funny don't don't
common from you hey I'm the ocean glass
of water
why are you so wet that's a Terrell
annoying hey well I'm a [ __ ] forest
fire matches what the [ __ ] are you doing
alright
I have some hair i'm follically
challenged but i had a hair transplant
nine years ago and those days are behind
me you definitely have more hair than
you did yeah that's weird
no it's called a hair transplant did it
hurt it didn't take I had the only last
one where they take a strip out of your
head would you have more hair than you
used to how did it hurt what does it do
what do you do yeah they take a strip
out of your [ __ ] this is now they do
it follicle by follicle Jesus back then
in 1963 they take
strip of your hair and under a
microscope they take the follicles out
they literally dig holes in your scalp
Diggle they numb you up yep and they put
the follicles in the holes it's such a
primitive way to do it then it takes
about a month to heal so what we were in
hats you look like [ __ ] Tom Hanks and
Philadelphia scabbed up I had 1,100
grafts but they didn't didn't really my
mother was like I don't think that
worked
oh the good thing is it probably only
cost 20 grand it cost like 11 grand
Jesus I made my dad pay for it cuz nice
he goes if you do it as my guinea pig
I'll do it maybe I'll get one more did
oh really but he paid for it your dad's
got he's bald her no he's got some hair
hmm he doesn't give a [ __ ] if you're
that age who cares I feel like once you
get past 45 who really gives a [ __ ]
some people do though some people I
guess if you're an actor nothing worse
than a six year old guy who dyes his
hair black oh that that yeah no that's
good do you have like wrinkles and
you're like older and you're yeah yeah
be [ __ ] older I'm never getting Botox
or any that [ __ ] just be older well if
you're an actor it's kind of annoying
cuz you got a diet a little bit
sometimes I guess I mean I never have
but I'm getting grey on my cheeks though
you have a great beard yeah can I put a
gray beard hell yeah sometimes I dye my
beard with just for men because my my
droves of fans know they tend to look at
this look at Bruce Jenner right he used
to dye his hair yeah just do you guys
well adjusted you have to be an older
guy look it now let's take a minute take
a minute this guy look at this [ __ ]
guy I'm looking hit he's wearing makeup
that's right that was Newton Wayne and
Wayne Newton so Wayne Newton has had his
eyes and face tightened and his hair
done that's that is that is pathetic
looking to me you don't look good he's
that that's a terrible look on a man but
look at Eddie uh getting Kenny Loggins
is that by the way no Kenny
but by the way it doesn't look good even
on a girl it doesn't yeah these guys
would get they get look at [ __ ] uh
Tom Jones
Tom Jonah gate when you get your eyes
done guys will get their eyes time to
get their eyes he's just
I mean Tom Jones looks like he's in a
jon favreau costume is she he looks like
he's in China [ __ ] yeah I wanna be
William for Halloween I'm gonna be Jon
Favreau who sings The Gambler Kenny
Rogers Kenny Rogers bring up Kenny
Rogers he got his he got his [ __ ]
eyes done I don't get it man
that I think it looks terrible terrible
mmm see you look good he looks good back
there he was an older man that they look
great it was 32 there sure was no look
though he got his eyes done look at him
whoa come on bro
don't be vain don't be vain as a man be
[ __ ] old yeah be an old guy I'm gonna
go I'm gonna be an old guy who looks
weird it does it looks it doesn't look
right he's trying to be pretty what are
you doing you tighten in your face look
at it look there's no snow no wrinkles
on his face it looks awful I'll do
testosterone get muscular a [ __ ] dude
I don't want tight face well but don't
do this I'm doing deck Hannibal I'm
gonna get huge why because I want to get
veined up and massive for once in my
life because I'm I'm ashamed of myself
no good I hate myself you got a you got
a real bad yeah brain I kind of bad but
why um why do you guys only entitle your
episodes with the number why don't you
have an essence its raw and it's what
you get oh Jesus Christ it's it's pure
and this podcast is the truth you know
let's let's go let's talk about this for
a second yeah I I am the best guess you
guys get that's not Fame wise I get you
get for more famous people but when I
come on good dish okay
when I come on baboom all right okay
don't take we're not we're not on a
spacecraft but you know I you do fine
it's all good and don't be a dick but my
[ __ ] do I get the most hits on your
podcast I don't know I do Jenny does
I mean maybe if you had [ __ ] Ilan
have you had like anybody like Elon Musk
but when it comes to c-listers like me
see this does like me you get massive
hits
what are you what level I'm an acapella
I'm a mama imma like at all imma like a
Barrett you're not a Sikh I'm a baritone
Shem
ba ba ba ba nobody I don't do duets I
really don't I do solo dances no I don't
do it
I did see if you're singing I go like
this or like that but when you stop I go
no see you sound like a dog but I sound
like a [ __ ] dog Leah's gonna be 40
and then things are gonna die gonna die
your hair falls out no it's not my dad's
got a full head of hair so did everyone
in my family hope your dad will just
money because the well is gonna run dry
no no I mean yeah yeah um but I'll be
fine dude hey but wait did I forget what
does it say that's what happens with us
we get on bits we get a bit so we keep
going and we forget what we're gonna say
but we always come back yeah or
sometimes we just come what no dude
how about what do you think of this one
wanna talk about talk about this on my
podcast a little bit but what do you
think of [ __ ] okay mmm came out with
this album you didn't listen to it
because you don't do [ __ ] like that no
but here's the deal he came out with an
album okay
and it dissed a lot of a dissed I hate
saying dis cuz I said super white but
that's what they call it yeah okay he
dissed a lot of the guys that [ __ ]
dissed him right
oh and so now he comes out with an album
that's like [ __ ] this game [ __ ] that
right all that [ __ ] and then other
rappers like this younger rapper that's
28 Machine Gun Kelly okay made a whole
song dissing mm now I have a [ __ ]
thing I want to say about this he grown
man Ryman you're grown man okay but it's
still really big and people love it it's
like a soap opera right yeah
what do you think of that what do you
think of grown men who are 46 if they
are self-aware enough to realize that
it's a good marketing ploy or then I'm a
fan if they're like yeah you go out from
the era if they're for real and Abbie's
[Laughter]
put on the WAP just watch the video here
go ahead play it you see it here we go
this is this is machine Machine Gun
Kelly now watch this [ __ ]
responding to mmm now look at him those
are tattoos I mean he's a cool-looking
dude he's a cool-looking cat yeah yeah
yeah I did he walks like he's got some
[ __ ] going on you know yeah
he doesn't need a shirt what do you
think of this you know what I like about
it I'm just curious of what you now not
even for your old man right like that
he's 51 I like that he's taking
something that that probably annoys him
right and turning it into probably five
million dollars yeah and also like a
pretty cool well written sorry right
right so in that sense I don't mind
right
he's also the Youngblood yeah Eminem's
the old light so young the young blood
is gonna use SERP the older one yeah in
music all of us as men at my age and
Eminem's age you do one thing we will
all face is a form of a death there are
teenagers that can beat me up now
there's all kinds of things you just
lose your body breaks there right
everything even you artistically or not
as relevant you have to stand ups a
little bit different but you're still
not gonna be head and be different
you're still gonna be the guy who is you
become the sort of the guy who becomes
the stalwart the the the keeper you're
not gonna go out and adventure mmm right
so young people like that he's the
adventurer you know that story about you
know with harvester ants you ever hear
the story I mean you take on a lot about
drop them in the middle of nowhere they
will slowly they'll take the younger
ants and the young hands will go out
like a half inch out and explore and
then come back and they come back in the
middle and you older aunts
they older as they space throw up in the
older aunts mouth just show them what's
out there and the older echoes okay go
back out there again they'll go out
another half inch so it's the younger
ants that actually expand the colony by
exploring and then they find they
finally find a food source and then they
find out
a nest but it's the younger ones that do
that and the older ones stay in the
middle and they stay put
so in that actually bad phenomenon
replicates itself all the way through
the animal kingdom and among people too
so young people like that are always
pushing the envelope and in a way
killing off the old order so I like that
anthropological point of view so anyway
the point is you're me there's something
about him that's very committed right
loose body right and he's he's actually
good I don't know rap but he said oh
yeah he makes good music um I just was
curious what you thought about it being
a [ __ ] so but it's real and now now
what did what did Eminem well okay so
what happened was he MGK Machine Gun
Kelly tweeted or something about his
daughter six years ago and his daughter
was like you know at that point sixteen
his daughter no Eminem's daughter he
tweeted about it like oh she looks hot
or something as a joke right I mean
that's what he says it was a joke
so Eminem came out with a line or two in
his new album and he was like keep my
daughter out your mouth you know and you
you you know who you are stop [ __ ]
your piece of [ __ ] or the [ __ ] you said
in rap terms can I hear that yeah yeah
but it's like in the middle of a song
and I don't know where it is but um yeah
anyway I mean it is interesting though
what is interesting is how talented
Eminem is and how good he is and you
know arguably well I mean he is one of
the best of all time but like how it
just it rap is such a young man's game
and it doesn't matter after a certain
point like like like jay-z who jay-z is
so who is so you know good and still
relevant if he wasn't with Beyonce and
they weren't doing their thing together
it would not be as interesting because
he's just rapped as a young man's game
young man's game but also like I think
when people listen to rap young people
so for me to listen to rap it's got eggs
like I appreciate rat right I do
actually I'll listen to jay-z NAS and I
listen to Tupac I listen to everything
cuz I think he's incredible and an
Eminem and then a couple others that
people turn me on to right and I end DMX
and just some of the big ones the big
and I really do appreciate the way
they're able to create emotional and
emotional response from a dude like me
who has never yeah yeah yeah I really do
appreciate it from an artistic
standpoint but there's also thing about
rap that is a young man's game in that
when you're driving it makes you feel
like a badass it makes you feel your
charge it doesn't as an older guy it's
an older guy it's not relevant yeah I'm
not I'm not a yeah I'm a badass you're
not driving or another damn about us
appreciate it from an artistic point of
view from the outside in when you're
young we get you fired up you're getting
ready you're going out you just want
noise whatever it does whatever that
thing does yeah it's full of
possibilities you're thinking about your
future
all that [ __ ] so when you're older and
you're singing about [ __ ] and by the way
the biggest enemy to an artist might be
especially a rapper might be millions of
dollars yeah no that's the truth what
are you angry about anymore an assistant
at staff yeah where everything is free
right including all the cars or houses
that is that's you know a problem
that's why great art always comes from
the [ __ ] most broken-down cities and
areas because you don't you you know you
don't have [ __ ] and you're desperate to
say yeah you gotta say him another huge
thing about being artistic is like the
terrifying notion that you won't be hurt
or you won't make it or you won't have
anything to say and so fun the first
time you make someone laugh as a comic
or the first time you realize that you
might be talented or you can do this
holy [ __ ] yeah and I think it's really
important as comics to keep that the one
thing about comedy that I think keeps
you honest is we have to keep
reinventing ourselves yes I shoe my
special I got to come up with tricks
yeah right and music you can sing the
same songs your stones are still sing
through art me up we can't do I know but
you you uh is why I'm still the like in
in the comedy world from what you again
if you were to boil it down which I do
every day right so when you boil it down
when they talk about me that's why I'm
the answer you know no no
the best which i think is stupid because
the answer all the cure I'm the curate a
right but when you go after me it's
tough
don't it so I'm glad you brought this up
on it's tough and I don't say sir like
this but it's probably did art we did
the spec we did the charity yeah I
followed you and I know destroy no no
you had a rough night minutes and then
you [ __ ] kind of something at the end
oh I am at the end you go like until
next time
no should do this would be your new
couch for it that's a [ __ ] thing to
say I got up and it was as though I took
out you know what a street sweeper is I
do know what a street sweeper but no no
but but you don't when it comes to guns
you know what a street sweeper is oh
it's it's it's a guns it's a gun that
shoots shotgun like shells almost
automatically so you can just cover a
whole street there's a street sweeper
over see that drum see the drum okay
don't you say it like this ROM there it
is okay right there that's now if you're
in in any area any area you will see you
later yeah okay because you're always
that's why I did the equivalent of
putting it in your mouth and I got along
the triggers that's what you know that's
what no I like good good good good good
and and it was almost as though nobody
had to see comedy anymore no dude you
don't you don't do what do you you don't
do well right like on the road you don't
wanna do well Chris what is your special
coming out on seeso no I was being
shopped as we speak cool now we'll see
what happens so you're out there going
door-to-door no no no I'm not
yeah let me tell you why you like this
special look you go into a [ __ ] room
let me tell you why it's special a lot
of guys in comedy ain't doing what I'm
doing now let me tell you what I'm doing
right first of all selling in the gas
class yeah right did you go in with a
[ __ ] with that a newsie hat and
you're just like I want to talk to you
guys about comedy now a guy my age why
am I still doing comedy when I'm not a
household name well I'll tell you why
first of all you need what's new and you
know I may not be what's new but I'm
faking it no and I'm faking it with the
best of them now let me just slide you a
sample here or what I do you play them a
clipping at half and then they go like
this hmm and you go like this now let's
talk some numbers and they go like this
get the [ __ ] out of here
oh they don't that's not you're being
disrespectful because I think what's
gonna happen is they're gonna go yeah
how long will it take to clear our whole
schedule no no no yeah dude
your subs is our there we know we don't
have those oh dude the truck is I'm too
busy and I can't be doing so when you
take and when you got a bad case the
clap and you take antibiotics well and
that clapped eyes on Tonto it gets it
gets splashed out of there there's a
wasteland we call it peace mmm right we
create a wasteland we create a wasteland
and call it peace after the vultures are
done with okay man when I went now that
my special is on the mark yeah hey dude
I'm uh what's your what's the name of
your special it was the last one you did
man on fire and then I got a new one
coming out called non stop non dude nom
that's right bro stop here it comes
knowing here it comes January I'm gonna
call I'm gonna call your why don't you
why don't you call your special no dude
that's what the be getting that confuse
with what the people are gonna say to
you when you try to shop it to their
networks boom I get you a good bro I get
you good dude how long has it been since
we've been talking by the way how long
we've been doing just about an hour oh
dude that's your flew by thank you very
much Chris you're welcome dude let's
shake your hand you've been what kind of
workout yeah I know you've been
obsessing over working out
you know that's what I do what are you
when I get something I got to do it all
the time you do bench you need to pull
down no dude I [ __ ] first of all do
any functional fitness well that's
[ __ ] I go on hikes first of all I do
a lot of [ __ ] and I climb here oh you
have a hiking body the first thing I say
is that guys oh [ __ ] hike dude I [ __ ]
climb dude I climb Rd I use your [ __ ]
hands on these markers man in Griffith
how dude and here's the other thing too
I do Sprint's at the gym let me tell you
something I am the I am the biggest
[ __ ] at the gym I am working out so
hard I'm drenched and nobody else's no
you your dress you drenched doing what
Sprint's j-rok you have a trainer ass
you don't know how to do any I do dude I
had a trainer and now I know how to do
it so I [ __ ] you know alright and I
go [ __ ] sprints like I do do what you
do when was the last time you worked out
well yes oh you know I did yesterday
what you know what I did yesterday what
did you do this is how much of a [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] I am keep due on
Labor Day I was like a [ __ ] coffee
shop yeah and I [ __ ] ran home I did
in here in my [ __ ] outfit dude
I ran home how far was it what was like
two miles you know k ran home now when
you say in their hand
don't you mean you plotted no I ran dude
I jogged okay you plotted know I jog
look when you were running it was this
hot is a story where were your wrists
pinned at your ribs and were you looking
up with your chest arch no dude that's
how you I was down and I was going like
this don't think yeah you're had people
make I know it was hard to people kept
stopping in cars and me like you're
hilarious
no I think what you were doing is you
were you had your arms because you're
not athletic
I'm very often not an athlete well I'm
very athletic so you you you arch your
back like a Chiquita banana hey Timmy
yeah a [ __ ] disrespect I'll let that
one go
on your own pie I'm gonna let that one
go now I'm gonna let that you came up
real close to my face I'm gonna let that
go and I'm gonna describe you later all
right bro guide your wrist pin it [ __ ]
off
smacked you do it one more [ __ ] time
then what I'm coming at you you run with
your body and you have your wrist
dude right right right yeah you can't
get vital jumps out here I'm spindly
dude how are you so spindly I know you
can't your new shirt you're Cassius Clay
new shirt you love [ __ ] fighter
that's so disrespectful that you smack
my face a bunch of times I could
literally see you for a salt well I
would make a [ __ ] dad this has been a
terrible podcast go to [ __ ] little [ __ ]
that's right now I've been the [ __ ]
shoes don't ever rat me with your
knuckles I had the best part I had the
best podcast here thanks guys we did it
what's up man I'm Jack what one was last
time I'm just have you ever been in the
Sun dude I go I forgive you must know
vitamin Daniel now dude I just my skin
is honestly too strong it goes like this
weed on the we don't need it do you know
what I think well and this you know what
makes me sad what and it makes me sad
what I think you're gonna die before
you're 40 bro yeah that's in two years
you know you mean up out of old age yeah
I can't nah bro that's not cool I'm
gonna be sad but I'm gonna tell Josie
your funeral because that's what you'd
want
oh god damn it I would feel bad about
Chris but he would want to turn this
into a comedy oh you know what I don't
even want to have a funeral you know
what I want when I die I want them to
just leave
wherever I am this locking collar just
like this until you just mummify up and
they go like this and it might my warm
iced Americanos not iced anymore it's
just warm in a they do that they do
embalm I saw that dude do embalming
sitting and doing your favorite that's
very weird I saw that hey don't have
that be happening but also current event
in it come on baby let's do it current
what are we doing the first one is Colin
Kaepernick's new Daiki I want to see
this it's causing a backlash it's just
like a post heated it says believe in
something even if it means that
everything is has a backlash you could
[ __ ] piss in a yeah I mean I this is
America what's great about this country
is you have two different size three
different sides and we are able to be
we're able to voice our opinion no but
not pick up guns and shoot each other
that's a huge difference
yeah yeah backlash is burning Nike gear
socks it's good for Nike it's good for
everybody yes I just felt 2% that's fine
yeah but that's that's they also
generated some crazy amount of money I
said forty three million dollars worth
of exposure yeah so of course it's out
oh yes I'm being it's if your stock
falls because you're doing that it's
probably a good thing come back Nike
he's not gonna go away cuz no business
you know business we don't what I'm when
I'm making a statement I don't need you
in the background [ __ ] you know
undermining me with your stupid mumbling
whatever dude the thing about Kaepernick
is get your [ __ ] a and your a in the
right place and your last name the
[ __ ] [ __ ] well it's probably
something like a dutch name probably
dude but let's get it let's figure it
out nineteen Americans are so
nationalistic so when you've dissed the
flag yeah I know get mad but I don't
think he was dissing the flag I think he
was just kneeling and saying hey here's
the bottom line you're supposed to
protest when you're not supposed to
protest that's it there's no such thing
as a protest when you're supposed to
you're allowed to do what he did but he
has paid consequence oh yeah
he's also probably richer now because of
it yeah so yeah but is he playing
football no no no no but he's suing the
NFL
because he thinks that top people have
conspired against him and talked about
not hiring him so he's suing the NFL
took guts to do what he did I'll tell
you that much
so yeah it definitely did anyway
everybody has their way of protesting
right like right now like your
personally I stand the flag because you
know that's how I feel you you're not an
American I am an American you're not
somebody who should ever represent
America and frankly I think you should
move to another country
well country oh my god sorry dude you
got boring men right so what we gonna do
about that but your hair is protesting
right what does that mean this is LSD Oh
Chris don't take LSD on my show
can't wait dude okay I'm gonna be [ __ ]
hurry up before he starts to trip there
we go all right the other one is a big
story for some reason this Cosby Show
actor Geoffrey Owens he was just caught
in a Trader Joe's working at a Trader
Joe's and it made his Fox yeah so may
its of Fox News and they're just they're
just pointing out that some fans saw
this guy recognize them and they made a
story out of it this is see this whole
thing is idiotic I don't who cares he
was on a show 78 years ago by the way it
was a hit he was on it so few people are
on a hit yeah who gives a [ __ ] he's got
another job now I don't even get it
people were they saying Oh too bad or
what they are the backlash was people
getting pissed off that this was a story
well I understand that but it was like
but I don't but like were they was Fox
News saying something shitty about him
no that's another thing yeah what they
were like oh yeah somebody saw him do
this
is he's working an honest day but they
were they making fun of him I hope not I
don't know what they were they were just
surprised to see him yes I mean I think
that when you make it as an actor you
know and your honor you you think that
your life is gonna be one of Fame and
money and and then something that
doesn't work out for everybody so he's
doing what he's got to do which is
working at a good company and everyone's
applaud him for it see so masters shines
everything
and no but it doesn't seem that I didn't
understand it's a 26 years after one TV
job the guy looks different differently
as earning an honest living
yeah yeah I just I guess I missed the
part where they were where people were
making fun of them well I think they I
think taken a picture across I think
taking a picture of him and in that with
a stained shirt there is that sort of
look what he's doing now [ __ ] I guess so
yeah it's just weird that this man got
sensational I don't think that I think I
don't think that mister his [ __ ]
business is hardly to stay relative dude
that's everybody everybody everybody's
in his position though dak did he goes I
swept floors after the NFL if need be
I'll do it again good honest work
there's nothing to be ashamed of terry
coolers of course and they knock that
pad just showed me an article where
Tyler Perry is offering him a new job
nice so I guess it's I mean yeah sure
it's great man good he's good right now
there is something there is something
noble about a modest like day's work
like that like you can see him like a
shirt stained yeah and he looks like
he's been working hard all day and and
he's kind of caught the caught by
surprise somebody taking a picture of
him but he's in the middle of something
there's something dignified about that
whatever is interesting it's [ __ ]
he's doing what he's got to do now you
judge the [ __ ] at me yeah cuz you're a
racist oh I don't think that black
people should even be working well I've
heard you say that yeah but uh yeah yeah
good for him man he also looks like
somebody want to be around anyways the
story was why it was the story in the
first place and everyone reacting to it
right right good about America was a
slow news day and it also was Fox News
right yeah so he did probably like I was
an actor he was liberal let's put him
out there yeah always blown up more than
ever before so now you have to go yeah
Wow alright next one HBO did you know
they're dropping although really night
sex programs like you know sex I was
[ __ ] waiting for that like it's just
so like who what is that [ __ ] I knew
girls who did that stuff and guys
acting class they did they would be
involved in that softcore kind of stuff
but but what like but vide by the way I
would I would venture to say actually
not I think about it nothing and I mean
nothing
well if they're talking about real sex
and cathouse I don't get that [ __ ] but
like that whole late-night skinemax [ __ ]
yeah nothing's more entertaining period
he rehearse for my period good it's okay
[ __ ] awesome yeah because what is it
first of all real bad acting okay
horrible shots horrible lighting up
gut-busting Lee hilarious because of
that yeah and also they're [ __ ] on it
but they're not mm-hmm and they won't
show in and out dicks and [ __ ] shots I
thought so it'll show tits yes and and
then and then there's a story in between
yo I watch that [ __ ] yeah and but that's
not on it I don't know if that's on HBO
but that's on Cinemax but that's when I
was first in LA I had an affair with one
of the stars one of those well yeah
big-time girls she was you did though
that show you didn't like it and you
know what no ya headed back no yeah
no no I'm not no and then when you're
busting out and when you're busting out
you go until next time that's how you
buzz no let me see another let me see
one Sin City Sin City was the one I used
to watch as a kid I remember [ __ ] yeah
watched it yeah I don't know Hotel
erotica Louis garden that it was right
up my alley little bunch people you work
with Tina wooden husband Lauren hey well
I gotta go back 20 years to know the
girl that I was James the jump-off co-ed
confidential of course that's incredible
yeah they're all Cinemax ones great
movies yeah yeah they're great passion
Cove of course girl Fox of dolphin
alright
Wow all right well there you go it's
amazing it's amazing you'll see one
little MMA one what MMA sorry bruh hold
on mixed martial arts you alright
[ __ ] foreign [ __ ] I get it there's a
picture of George st. Pierre looking
smaller so the rumors are that he would
fight the winner of khabib and Conor the
biggest fight this year
oh he's less big than he used to be yeah
what do you think Bryan from what he
don't looks like um you know that's him
on the left on the right George's Day
you know Georges st. Pierre he's very I
know the name I don't know his face but
you know he's getting older I don't know
what his training is and so what his
training was I don't know oh yeah yeah
you didn't look like yeah oh that's that
guy I have my spots and all wow he looks
completely different yeah I didn't
realize that that was him that's in he's
probably sore do you think it's oh
nevermind I'm not even go there
but that guy on the left though is Bryan
Callen who's that guy you know when you
train when you when you do jiu-jitsu and
wrestling you Utes box and you're you're
training like an MMA fighter a lot of
times you can actually get skinnier like
you put on a lot of muscle car do ya
you're not lifting weight you know but
that's why when you see dudes like who
have been training and they get in the
ring and they're barrel-chested and
super muscular yeah they're they're
doing drugs they're doing steroids but a
lot of times like in the UFC with you
sada when you watch guys now when they
get in the ring it's it's not like
you're gonna see muscle-bound dudes it's
your body doesn't do that so mostly as
you get older with the Georges older
because you get older putting on muscle
is harder he's still a phenomenal
athlete and I still would have him in
both those fights because he's such a
genius so I'm you think he would be too
both of them I do he's just on oh my
goodness
yeah really genius he's much bigger than
Conor well I know that I couldn't handle
this wrestling mm-hmm I mean I don't
know what Conor does with with George
but I mean again George's but then again
George has been out for a long time I
don't know what kind of he's got to be
what 45 no he's like third Oh what 39 38
oh wow he looks older I'll be 38
God those got how insane $37 37 how
what's this guy worth how much does
somebody like that worth a lot George he
appears a genius at finding out where
you're weak he's such a strategist he
can find out exactly where your holes
are and he can be capitalized that long
he's a very special 30 million 30 money
- yeah he's a movie soon yeah he's a
very special human being in my opinion I
think George team Pierre is an extreme
winner I just love him and what he was
able to do when he fought was he's one
of the greatest of all time there's
nobody you know he's just he's amazing
in every way would you say on the stand
up version of him stamp comedy version
of him I'm asking I'm saying no so no
come on you're not you're a hater cuz
you're cuz I'm your friend and you're
worried that your friends got a little
moving heat on him through being a hater
so just saying that oh not I do think
you've burned so I am the George st.
Pierre Rick is about your wick is about
to be burned out Isaac cute kitten by
the way put him in you in a room he
takes turn he takes all your girls all
right I mean they don't even notice the
peanut-shaped face
well I'm 37 yeah he's younger than you
that's what happens as you get older and
he he vacuums up anything always from
Montreal more glad yeah that's not evil
well come on
well had you think he likes my bro dude
I don't think he knows who you are but
he sure as [ __ ] no he probably knows who
your cuz of this [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
podcast have you had him on here
no but could cuz Brendan's really good
friends though
okay well why hasn't he been honest he's
good friends with me okay
friends of Brennan friends of mine well
if I stand up no what were you guys
saying oh there's all the care of that
sucked today I love them look I'm glad
that this is done how about that my
[ __ ] this Park has killed um I can't
wait to see what the fan said thank you
very much everybody
can't wait to hear what you say where
are you gonna be Chris where are you
gonna be doing I don't know why don't
you just use what I want you unsubscribe
to this podcast distillation podcast and
then subscribe to mine take a video of
your phone on your phone and send it off
why'd you why'd you [ __ ] call it
congratulations because this is where we
are man you get a bunch of
congratulations for [ __ ] that you do
because you [ __ ] up the world [ __ ] up
and the world whether or not you're good
or bad for the world congratulations
dude you're impressive you impressively
are very good or you impressively [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up
alright so Hayden you know what
congratulations to you now dude you're
shopping you're special around
congratulate Jace alright I'm not they
are you're going door to door you know
we're not a question for you what door
to door salesman
dude how does it feel walking on a
pathway how does it feel
taking a shortcut over some guy's lawn
that's you bro congratulations
now don't listen this podcast because
you learn nothing and thank you for
tuning in to this podcast we ripped it
I'll buy you some lunch buddy yeah you
will no don't do the kissing thing man
this is the butter in the kid we're out